aviez vous avez quel rapport avec votre
père ce que c'est vrai que tout se
demande c'est vrai que c'est ccd quels
rapports et puis maintenant j'ai plutôt
avec lui plutôt nation tu contactes on
avait un contact comme a dit olivier
l'épistolaire c'était pour le lieu où l
enquête pour la reconstruction par la
vengeance on va dire à quoi dans
l'enfance jetèrent père pour moi c'est
un peu normal ça faisait pas ce qu'ils
faisaient non pas au courant après j'ai
appris récemment qu'ils ont parlé à tort
que choisit de sortir avec eux mes choix
j'ai pas de rappel de sa culture tout ça
c'était plus que tout est normal pour
moi c'était un père normal était pas
proche il te paternel mais voilà quand
j'entraînais papa maman il travaillait
beaucoup la maison brûle travaux la
maison est un chantier mais sinon je
m'attendais pas travailler le même soir
il possible que j'ai eu de mauvaises
notes
vous apprenez le jour de son
interpellation qui est votre papa en
fait c'est ça un jour de
l'interpellation
le jour où elle est arrêtée bien il a
tout vu tout le police dans la maison
minutes ne veut rien dire
il sait pas c'est le plus tard que j'ai
appris la vérité tu n'en avais une fille
qui s'est échappé mais c'est seulement à
1 502 monique dans les médias que j'ai
appris tout ce qui s'est passé au lit
selim ça cesse
ça lui fait mal ce sauf cette fiction
qui va arriver là dans quelques jours
est-ce qu'ils appréhendent quand vous
vous sentez vous ce que vous êtes voilà
très pro joly sur dix qui la présentent
ce moment ce 15 mars
oui bien sûr essayer il ressent beaucoup
d'empathie pour les victimes
il n'a pas ce détachement d'ailleurs
quand on a fait l'émission balle reste
il reste à des petits rigolos il a été
très marqué par la fille d'emile louis
et il sait que lui il est c'est un
survivant et il a quand même réussi à
réussir malgré tout il incarne un
symbole d'espoir mais il sait que ce
n'est pas le cas de tout le monde
notamment deux de ses proches qui ont
été impactés aussi par cette affaire
donc
aujourd'hui c'est pour ça qu'il est si
actif et qu'il entend voilà faire valoir
la le respect pour les familles des
victimes à des victimes en soi